The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: The outline for today
is a little bit more review
of feeling the power of the
creation and annihilation
operators.
They enable you to do anything
with harmonic oscillators,
really fast.
And so you don't
spend time thinking
about how to do the math.
You think about the meaning of
the problem and understanding
how to manipulate,
or how to understand
harmonic oscillators.
And then the exciting thing.
The real Schrodinger
equation is not the one
we've been playing with.
It's the time dependent
Schrodinger equation.
And I like to introduce
the time independent one
first, because it enables you
to sort of develop some insight
and assemble some of
the tools before we
hit the really serious stuff.
And so I will talk about this
and use the time dependent
Schrodinger equation
to show what
it takes to get a motion of this
product of the psi star psi.
What does it take?
It takes a superposition
state consisting of at least
two different energies.
Then this normalization
integral--
well, you'd expect
normalization, or something
like this to be preserved.
And in fact, the normalization
is time independent.
Then, if we calculate--
now, this is a vector rather
than just a simple coordinate.
If we calculate the expectation
value of the position,
and the expectation
value of the momentum,
Ehrenfest's theorem
tells you that this
is going to describe the motion
of the center of the wave
packet.
And the motion of the
center of the wave packet
is following Newton's laws.
No surprise.
And so we're seeing
how classical mechanics
is given back to
you once we start
making particle-like states.
We can see how these
particle-like states evolve.
But there is a lot more than
just particle-like behavior.
You would, perhaps, challenge
any outfielder for the Red Sox
to go beyond calculating the
center of the wave packet.
That's what they know to do.
But they don't know
some other things
like survival
probability, how fast
does the wave packet move
away from its birthplace,
or the wave packet does stuff
and wanders around and comes
back and rephases sometimes.
And sometimes it just dephases.
And these are words that
you're going to want
to put into your vocabulary.
So there's a lot of
really beautiful stuff
when we start looking at the
time dependent Schrodinger
equation.
And we are going to mostly
consider the time dependent
Schrodinger equation
when the Hamiltonian is
independent of time, because
we can get our arms around that
really easily.
But when the Hamiltonian
is dependent on time,
then it opens up a
world of complexity
that is really best left
to a more advanced course.
But how do molecules get excited
from one state to another?
A time dependent Hamiltonian.
So we are going to have
to at least briefly talk
about a time dependent
Hamiltonian and what it does.
And you'll see that eventually.
I'm first going to do
a little bit of review
of the a's and a daggers.
So the most important
thing is, we're
going to have some problem
where we have this x operator
to some integer power.
And so we need to be
able to relate that
to the a's and a daggers.
I'll drop the hats, because
we know they're there.
And one of the nice things
is, if we have this operator
to the nth power, we have this
co-factor to the nth power.
So we don't ever
have to deal with it
until the end of the problem
when we say, oh, wow, we
had x to the n.
Well, we have then n h bar.
I'm sorry.
We have h bar over 2
mu n n over 2 power.
So it really saves
a lot of writing.
And it means you
solve one problem
for a harmonic oscillator.
And you've solved it for
all harmonic oscillators.
And this is just details
about what is the mass
and what is the force constant,
which you need to know.
And there is a
similar thing for p.
So that opens the door.
It says, OK, we have
some problem involving
the coordinate and the momentum,
some function of the coordinate
and momentum, and we
want to know things
about the coordinate
and momentum.
And so we use this
operator algebra.
And so a operating on psi v
gives v square root v minus 1.
And a dagger, we know that.
So that's hardwired.
But suppose we
wanted a to the 5th,
operating on psi v.
Well, what do we do?
Well, we start, and we
start operating on...
You know, if this were
a complicated operator,
we would take the rightmost
piece of that operator
and operate on
the wave function.
And that will give us v and then
v minus 1 and then v minus 2,
v minus 3.
I've got five of them.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
v minus 4.
Square root psi v minus 5.
OK.
It's mechanical.
You don't remember this.
You generate this
one step at a time.
And it's automatic.
And so it doesn't
stress your brain.
You can be thinking
about the next thing
while you're writing
that garbage.
We have this number
operator, which
is a friend, because
it enables you to just
get rid of a bunch of terms.
The number operator is a dagger
a, and the number operator
operating on psi
v gives v psi v.
If we want any harmonic
oscillator function,
we can operate on psi 0 with
a dagger to the v power.
And then we have to
correct, because you
know that this operating v
times on this will give psi v.
But it will also give a
bunch of garbage, right?
And you want to
cancel that garbage.
And so you write v
factorial minus 1/2.
And so that gives you
the normalized function.
So these are really,
really simple things.
And most of them, once you've
thought about it a little bit,
you can figure out yourself.
OK.
Now, many problems involve
x, x cubed, x to the 4th.
And we know that x is this.
And x squared is this squared.
And x cubed is this cubed.
And so we have to do a
little algebra to simplify.
And what we want to do is
simplify to sum of terms
according to delta
v selection rule.
So there is some
algebra that we do,
when we have, say, a dagger,
a dagger, a, a, a dagger.
But we know that three a
daggers and two a's means
delta v of plus 1.
And that came from
x to the 5th power.
But you get a lot of terms
from x to the 5th power.
And you have to simplify them.
And in order to do that, you
use this commutation rule--
a, a dagger is equal to 1.
And that rearranges terms.
So all of the work
you do when you're
faced with a problem
involving integrals
of integer powers of x and
p for a harmonic oscillator
is playing around with
moving the a's and a daggers
around, so that you
have all the terms that
have the same selection rule
compressed into one term.
That's the work.
It's not much.
And once you've done it for
x squared, x cubed and x 4th,
you've done it as much as
you'll ever need to do.
And that's it.
That's the end.
OK.
Now here's an
example of a problem
that's a little bit tricky.
And it's sort of right
at the borderline of what
I might use on the exam.
So we have this, we have
a dagger to the m power.
A to the n power.
Psi.
OK.
Now, here.
What v is going to give
a non-zero integral?
We have a dagger to the m.
And we have a to the n.
And so that's going to be
v minus n plus m, right?
Because we lose n
quanta, because of this.
And we gain m quanta
because of that.
And now, well, that's good.
You've used the selection rule.
Now, how do we write
out this interval?
And there is a little
bit of art there too.
Because we have a
whole bunch of terms.
We have n plus m terms
in the square root.
And how do you generate
them without getting lost?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I think you
have it backwards.
Shouldn't it be plus n minus n?
It means you're going
to lower it n times.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Yes.
I wonder what I had in my notes.
This is wrong.
OK.
So this has to
withstand this and this.
And so, yes.
OK.
However you remember it,
you've got to do it right.
And now we have the
actual matrix element.
And so the first term is going
to be what does a n do to that?
So you start on the right.
And you start
building up this way.
And so the first term is going
to be, what does a do to this?
Well, it's going
to leave it alone.
But it's going to lower v.
So we have v plus n minus m.
And then we have v
plus n minus m minus 1,
et cetera, until
we have n terms.
And then we start going
back up, because we're now
dealing with this.
And so I'm not going to
write the rest of this.
Maybe this is going to be a
problem I start the exam with.
So you don't want to get lost.
And the main thing is,
you have these operators.
And you start operating on the
right, and one step at a time.
And this is a little
tricky because you're
changing the quantum
number, and you're
changing the wave function.
And you have to
keep both in mind,
but you're only
writing down this.
OK?
I want to save enough time
so that we can actually
do the time dependent
Schrodinger equation.
The time dependent
H psi.
It still looks pretty simple.
Instead of e psi here,
we have this thing.
This is the time dependent
Schrodinger equation.
This is it.
This is quantum mechanics.
Everything that comes
from quantum mechanics
starts with this.
When we don't care
about time, we
can use the time independent
Schrodinger equation.
But when we do
care about time, we
have to be a little bit careful.
So this is the real
Schrodinger equation.
And notice that
I'm using a capital
psi, rather than a lower
case, or less decorated psi.
And so this is usually used
to indicate the time dependent
Schrodinger equation.
It's time dependent
wave function.
This is used to indicate the
time independent equation.
Now, if the Hamiltonian--
and this is wonderful--
if the Hamiltonian is
independent of time,
then if we know the
solutions psi n en.
If we know all of
these solutions,
then there's nothing new.
We just are
repackaging the stuff
that we know from the time
independent Schrodinger
equation.
So the first thing I
want to do is to show you
that if the Hamiltonian
is independent,
we can always write a
solution to the time
dependent Schrodinger
equation-- e to the minus i e n
t over h bar psi n x.
So this, for a time
independent Hamiltonian,
is always the solution of the
time dependent Schrodinger
equation.
So we're just using
this stuff that we know,
or at least we barely
know, because we just
started playing the game.
But we can manipulate to see
all sorts of useful stuff.
OK.
So let's show if this form
satisfies the Schrodinger
equation.
So we have ih bar partial
PSI with respect to t.
So we get an ih bar.
And then we take the
partial with respect to t.
This is independent of time.
This has time
[INAUDIBLE] And so we
get a minus i e n over h bar.
And then we get e to the minus
i e n t over h bar psi n of x.
Well.
So, let's put this together.
We have an i times
i times minus 1.
So that's plus 1.
We have an h bar in
the numerator and h
bar in the denominator.
That's 1.
And so what we end up getting
is e n e to the minus i e n
t over h bar psi n.
Well, this is psi.
This function here is
the solution to the time
dependent Schrodinger equation.
How do we know that?
Well, we have this
factor, h psi.
Well, h doesn't operate
on either the i e n t.
So what we have is that we
get E n e to the i omega t.
Sorry.
I'm jumping ahead.
i e n t over h bar psi.
All right.
So, if we apply the
Hamiltonian to this function,
we get just e n
times the function.
And that's what we got when
we did i h bar times a partial
with respect to t.
So what that shows is
that this form always
satisfies the time dependent
Schrodinger equation, provided
that the Hamiltonian
is independent of time.
Now, that's a large
range of problems, things
that we need to understand.
But it's not the whole potato,
because the Hamiltonian
is often dependent on time.
But it enables us to
build up insight, and then
treat the time dependence
as a perturbation.
And we're going to do
perturbation theory in the time
independent world.
And then we're going to
do perturbation theory
a little bit in the
time dependent world.
OK.
So what we always do here is
we solve a familiar problem,
and then we say, OK, well,
there's something more
to this familiar problem.
And so we treat that
as something extra.
And we work out the
formalism for dealing
with that extra thing.
But before we do
the extra thing,
we have to really
kill the problem that
is within our grasp.
OK.
So now, our job
is to just explore
what we've really got here.
So the first problem is motion.
So we have psi star
x and t psi x and t.
So we have this
thing, which we're not
going to integrate yet.
Well, when is this
thing going to move?
Well, the only way this
probability density
is going to evolve
in time is going
to be if we have a
wave function, psi,
which is of x and t is equal to
c1 psi 1, e to the minus i e 1,
e over h bar, plus c2,
psi 2, e to the minus i e
2, t over h bar, where
e1 is not equal to e2.
So this is the first,
most elementary step.
And remember, we have this
notation e to the i something.
And e to the minus i something.
And when we take a plus 1 and
a minus and put them together,
we get 1.
So this notation, this
exponential notation,
is really valuable.
OK.
So now let's just look at
this quantity, psi star psi.
OK.
Psi star psi.
Well, it's going to be c1
squared, psi 1 squared--
square modulus-- and we
get c2 square modulus,
psi 2 square modulus.
Are we done?
No.
So, what we did is, I put
in c1, psi 1 plus c2, psi 2.
And I looked at the
easy terms, the terms
where the exponential
factor goes away.
And then there's
two cross terms.
Those two cross
terms are c1 star--
whoops-- c2 e to the minus
i e 2 minus e1 t over h bar
psi 1 star, psi 2.
And we have c1, c2 star e
to the plus i e2 minus e1
t over h bar, psi 1 star.
psi 1, psi 2 star.
Now, this is just the
automatic writing.
OK.
So we have two terms that
are time independent.
So, this is no big surprise.
But then we have
this stuff here.
And if we say e2 minus e1
over h bar is omega 2, 1,
everything becomes
very transparent,
because now we
have something that
looks like it looks like it's
trying to be a cosine omega t.
We have to be a
little bit careful.
These are the two
time dependent terms.
And they are the complex
conjugate of each other.
And so we know that if we
have two complex numbers,
c plus c star, we're going to
get twice the real part of c.
So this enables us to take these
two terms and combine them.
And we know it had
better be real,
because we're talking
about a probability here.
This probability
has got to be real.
And it's got to be positive.
It's got to be real and
positive everywhere and forever.
Because there's no such thing
as a negative probability.
There's no such thing as
a negative probability
in a little region of
space, and we say, well,
we integrate over all space,
and so that goes away.
This psi star psi is going to
be real everywhere for all time.
And so that's a good
thing, because we
have a sum of a plus
its complex conjugate.
And so this is real.
And we can simplify everything,
and we can write it simply.
But suppose we choose
a particular case--
c1 star is equal to
c1, which is equal to 1
over square root of 2.
And we can say psi 1
and psi 2 are real.
When we do that, then this
complicated-looking thing, psi
star psi, becomes
1/2 psi 1 squared,
plus 1/2 psi 2 squared, plus
cosine omega 1 2 t psi 1 psi 2.
OK.
Well, these two
guys aren't moving.
And they're real.
And positive.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Wait, is c2 also
1 over square root of 2?
PROFESSOR: I had 1
over square root of 2,
one over square root of 2.
That's 1/2.
But then when you
add the two terms,
you get twice the real part.
So we get a 1/2 times 2.
And so this is not a mistake.
It comes out this way, OK?
AUDIENCE: I think you meant c2.
You're only finding c1 star and
c1 to be 2 over square root--
1 over square root of 2.
You didn't say
anything about c2.
PROFESSOR: Oh.
OK.
I want c1 and c2.
That's what I wanted.
OK.
Thank you.
That shows you're listening.
And it shows that
I'm sufficiently here
to understand your
questions, which
is another wonderful thing.
So this is now,
we have something
that's positive everywhere.
It's time independent.
And we have something
that's oscillating.
And so this term
can be negative.
But you can show--
I don't choose to do that.
You can show that this
term is never larger
than psi 1 squared
plus psi 2 squared.
And so even though this term
can be negative at some points,
it never is a negative enough
to make the evolving probability
go negative.
Now, you may want to play with
that just to convince yourself.
And it's an easy proof.
And I'm just not going to do it.
OK.
So we have something
that says, just
like for the wave equation,
what does it take to get motion?
And to get motion
you had to have
a superposition of two
waves of different energy
or different wave vector.
And so here we have, if
e1 is not equal to e2,
we have a non-zero omega 1, 2.
It doesn't matter whether it's
omega 1, 2, or omega 2, 1,
because it's cosine.
And so that's motion.
So we get a standing
wave sort of situation.
And then we get this motion.
OK, now, the fun begins.
Suppose we want to calculate the
expectation value of x and p.
OK.
And let's just take
it as a 1D problem.
And so x of t.
No, there was no question.
All right.
We have--
OK.
And again, we take
this thing apart.
And we say, all right, suppose
we have the same superposition
of psi is equal to c1.
psi 1.
OK.
Actually, these should
be the time independent.
So what we get is, when we
do this integral, we get c1
squared integral psi
star x, psi 1 dx.
And we get c2 squared integral
psi 2 star x, psi 2 dx.
And then we get cross
terms. c1 star, c2.
e to the minus i omega 2, 1 t
times the integral psi 1 star
x psi 2 dx.
And we have c1, c2 star,
e to the plus i omega 2 1
t integral psi 2
star x psi 1 dx.
A lot of stuff here.
Now, we're talking about
the harmonic oscillator.
This integral is 0.
Because x is a plus a dagger.
The selection rule is delta
v of plus and minus 1.
This one is 0.
For the particle in
a box, one can also
ask, what about this integral?
And for the particle in a
box, it's a little bit more
complicated.
Because we've chosen a
mathematically simple way
to solve the particle in a
box, with the box having a zero
left edge.
If we make the box symmetric,
then we can make judgments
and say, oh, yeah.
This integral is also 0
for the particle in a box.
And that's a little bit more
complicated, the argument,
than what I just did.
So these two terms are 0.
And now we have motion of the
expectation value, which is
described by these two terms.
And again, they're the complex
conjugate of each other.
And so what we have is
x of t is equal to twice
the real part of c1 star, c2
e to the minus i omega 2, 1 t.
Times x 1, 2.
OK.
This x 1, 2 is an integral.
So x 1, 2 if these are the
vibrational quantum numbers,
well, then this is non-zero.
This is just the square root
of 2, or square root of 1.
OK.
So we have motion
described by this.
And so the only
time we get motion
is if v1 is equal to
v2 plus or minus 1,
for the harmonic oscillator.
For the particle in a box,
there's different rules.
And often, for these
simple problems,
you want to go through in your
head all of the simple cases.
Now, we already can see that--
I don't want to talk about
the particle in a box.
So now let's just
take another step.
And we're going to have
Ehrenfest's theorem, which
you can prove, says that m times
the derivative of vector p--
so this is a time dependent
expectation value--
is equal to--
I'm sorry.
This is not vector p.
This is vector r--
is equal to--
So this is the vector p.
So this is the derivative
of the coordinate,
with respect to time.
That's velocity.
Velocity times mass is momentum.
And so we have a relationship
between the expectation
value of the position
and the expectation
value of the momentum.
And that's for
Newton's first law.
And then there is another
Newton's equation translated
into quantum mechanics.
So we have the expectation
value of the momentum, dt,
is equal to minus
the expectation
value of the potential.
While this is acceleration
times mass, and this is force--
minus the gradient of a
potential is the force--
these are Newton's
two equations.
And what they're saying is,
if we know these things,
we know something about the
center of the wave packet,
and how the center of
the wave packet moves.
Now, the wave packet might
be localized at one time.
It might be mushed
out at another time.
But you can always calculate
the center of the wave packet.
It's just that there
are only certain times
that it looks like a particle.
But this thing,
these quantities,
which you define by an integral,
they evolve classically.
So I told you at
the beginning, you
had to give up
classical mechanics.
It's all coming back.
But it's coming back in a
quantum mechanical framework,
because we're talking now
about wave functions, which
have amplitudes and phases,
and can do terrible things.
But at certain limits, they're
going to act like particles.
But if you were to
ask a question, well--
suppose we do this experiment.
And so here we have an
electronic ground state
potential surface.
Now, I'm jumping way ahead.
But this is the wave function
for that vibrational level.
And you excite the molecule with
a time dependent Hamiltonian,
a time dependent
radiation field light.
And you vertically
transport this wave function
to the upper state,
until you get something
which is not an eigenstate.
It's a pluck.
This pluck is a
superposition of eigenstates.
And we can ask, how
does this evolve?
And what it's going
to do is, it's
going to start out localized.
And at some point, it'll
do terrible things.
And then at some
other time it'll
be localized again at
the other turning point.
And it will come back and forth.
And now, if it's not
a harmonic oscillator,
it won't quite relocalize.
It'll mush out a little
bit, and it'll come back
and it'll mush out more.
And so again, we can use the
evolution of the wave packet
to sample the shape
of the potential.
We can measure
the anharmonicity.
And so let's now
talk about that.
What are other
quantities that we
can calculate from the
wave function of the time
dependent Schrodinger equation?
So let's talk about the
survival probability.
So this is a capital P.
Survival probability.
It's going to be
the wave function.
The time dependent wave function
is created at t equals 0.
It has some shape.
Now, we always like to have
a simple shape at t equals 0.
And we'd like to know how
fast that thing moves away
from its birthplace.
So we have this
survival probability.
It's a probability.
So we're going to have
integral psi star xt psi xt dx.
And this integral is
going to look like that.
Now, whoops.
I knew I was going to screw up.
If I put a t here,
then it would just
be the normalization interval.
And we already
know what that is.
But this is the birthplace.
This is what was
created at t equals 0.
And this is time evolving thing.
And so we can calculate
how that behaves.
And I'm just going to
write the solution.
So the result is, if we have the
same kind of two state c1 psi
1, e to the minus
i e1 t for h bar
plus c2 psi 2 e to the
minus i e2 e over h bar,
well then, what we get
is c1 to the 4th power
plus c2 to the 4th power plus
c1 squared, c2 squared, times
e to the i omega 2, 1 t plus
e to the minus i omega 2, 1 t.
Now we're integrating.
When we integrate, the
wave functions go away.
The wave functions
become either 1 or 0.
And so we're integrating.
We're making the wave
functions go away.
And we have some amplitudes
of the wave functions.
And we have a time independent
part and a time dependent part.
And this is 2
cosine omega 2, 1 t.
So what we see is this survival
probability, the wave function,
starts out at some place.
And it goes away.
And it comes back.
And it does that.
It completely rephases,
because there's only two terms.
But if there were three
terms that are not
satisfying a
certain requirement,
then when it comes back,
it can't completely
reconstruct itself.
And this is the basis
for doing experiments.
One can observe the
periodic rephasings
of some initial pluck.
And you can look at
the decay of them,
and that gives you
something about the shape
of the potential,
the anharmonicity.
And you can do all sorts
of fantastic things.
You can create a
wave packet, and you
can wait until it reaches
the other turning point.
And at the other
turning point, it's
possible that you
could excite it
to a different
higher excited state.
Ahmed Zewail got the
Nobel Prize for that.
So we're right at the
frontier of what you can do,
and what you can
understand using
this very simple problem of a
time independent Hamiltonian
and a 2 or a 3
term superposition.
OK.
Recurrence.
This is a special property.
When all of the wave functions,
or all of the difference--
all of the energy levels, or
differences in energy levels
are integer multiples of
a common factor, well then
any coherent superposition
state you make
will rephase at a special time.
And so what we can do is say,
OK, for a particle in a box,
the energy levels are
e1 times n squared.
For our harmonic oscillator,
the energy level difference
is ev plus n minus
ev our n h bar omega.
For a rigid rotor, which
we haven't seen yet,
the energy levels are a function
of this quantum number j hcb.
This is the rotational
constant-- times j plus 1.
So all of the energy
levels are related.
I'm jumping ahead.
Sorry.
So the energy levels
are j times j plus 1.
And the differences,
ej plus 1 minus ej,
are given by 2 hcb
times j plus 1.
So for these three problems,
we have this perfect situation
where one can have
these oscillating
terms all have a common factor.
And at certain times, the
oscillating terms are all 1.
Or some are 1 and
some are minus 1.
And we get a really
wonderful simplification.
So at a time which
we call, or I call,
the grand recurrence
time, where it's
equal to h over e1 for this
case of the particle in a box,
or h over h bar omega,
or h over 2 hcb,
we get all of the phase
factors becoming 1.
And sometimes, something special
happens at the grand recurrence
time divided by 2.
And that's a little
bit like this.
We have a wave function here.
And at half the recurrence
time, it's over here.
And so you want to work
your way through the algebra
to convince yourself that
that is in fact true.
And in between, if
you have enough terms
in your superposition,
which is usually the case,
in between you get this.
You get garbage looking.
It's still moving.
It's still satisfying
the Ehrenfest theorem,
but it doesn't look
like a particle.
It just looks like garbage.
But you get these
wonderful things happening.
And now, if they're
not perfectly
satisfying this integer
rule, then each time you
get to a turning
point, the amplitude
has decreased and
decreased and decreased.
And at infinite
time, it might recur.
But nobody waits around
for infinite time,
because other things happen and
destroy the coherence that you
built. So this is a glimpse.
Time independent
quantum mechanics
is complicated enough.
Well, we can embed
what we understand
in the time dependent mechanics.
And there are a lot of beautiful
things that we can anticipate.
Now, we can use these
beautiful things
to do experiments
which measure stuff
that is related to, how does
energy move in the molecule?
What is going on
in the molecule?
What are the mechanisms
for stuff happening?
And in magnetic resonance,
there are all sorts
of pulse sequences that
interrogate distances
and correlated motions.
And it is really a laboratory
for time dependent quantum
mechanics with a time
dependent Hamiltonian.
But a lot of stuff that we do
with ordinary laser experiments
are usually understandable
in a time independent way.
Now, we want to get rid of
things that are complicated.
And so one of the
things that we do
is, we map a problem
onto something
which is time independent.
And so one of the
tricks that you will see
is that if we go into what's
called a rotating coordinate
system, this rotating
coordinate system
is rotating at an energy level
different divided by h bar.
And that converts the problem
into a time independent problem
in the rotating
coordinate system.
So that you're in a
rotating coordinate system
and, basically, you use the
ordinary perturbation theory.
And then you go back to the
non-rotating coordinate system.
So there's all sorts of tricks
where we build on the stuff
that we understood.
And we can have a picture
which is intuitive,
because we want to strip
away a lot of the mathematics
and see the universal stuff.
And so I'm going to try
to present as much of that
as I can during this course.
But a lot of the time
independent stuff
is heavy lifting, and I'm going
to have to do a lot of that
too.
OK.
Have a nice long weekend.
I'll see you on Monday.